hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play slender
hot
now I'm gonna big this game I'm gonna
finish it no matter how long it takes so
you better get settled get some popcorn
whatever you need to because I'm gonna
dumb and dumb nah I'm not gonna stop I'm
gonna March up to that factory power
plant whatever it is and I'm on a kick
Slendy in the balls
why is my mouse still there I don't even
care of it alright so we just need to go
straight out and then head right up the
road and that is it right right
wait no not that one not that one even
though Slendy is real nearby it's not
that one because I know this maybe oh
god I'm gonna get lost again I'm such an
a-hole
please tell me I'm not gonna get lost
yeah okay text from nobody hi ah
bollocks what where am I ah what what
the hell you son of a [ __ ] did you turn
me around too
oh no you did not okay now look at that
Oh mother Oh bodge I'm gonna take
another route I'm gonna just God the
door my turn right cuz I know that's
north yes yes yes yes you're done
like I said settle in cuz we're gonna be
here a while
hold on your horses I just head straight
this way it should get me exactly where
I need to go if I don't run smack into
Slendy which I might go like just
heading straight this way like a baller
procession where's the flashing lights
in the background where it's a siren
wait a minute got ten at ten where's
what the what was that who's that why is
it the factory not lit up don't tell me
oh don't tell me don't tell me that's
like a fog or something where if I save
after Gideon come back in the game the
factory's not lit up don't tell me that
all right headed in the wrong direction
no no I'm on the right way what is this
bollocks hey don't do that
God dad out okay something's going fishy
here I got all the pages in there in the
last one didn't the factory light up
maybe it didn't because I maybe I wasn't
paying attention but there should be no
other pages I've got ten of ten here and
I got oh yeah I got a key yeah I did get
a key cuz I remember it saying oh there
was a key behind that last page because
I got a key to the factory
oh stop it oh stop it you Oh
nothing can stop me now don't stop me
now cuz I'm having a good time there it
is
who can stop me now [ __ ] I can't sing
oh there it is
alright we're almost there gang Oh
buckle in
it's gonna be a bumpy ride sund'ys
apparently behind me and he's staying
the noise not you no he's not he was but
now he's not was behind me being a good
little Slendy and then he decided to be
an [ __ ] you all know what happens to
[ __ ] so follow the road just a
little bit more where's that damn fence
where's the damn fence need to
recuperate a bit and then I'll be on my
way
come on oh I can do this use all of my
slender real knowledge get this done
almost there almost there
oh man oh man I actually don't know
where the pages are in the factory
besides that one and that one was on the
bottom okay right here I'm right here
going in the factory whoa ever so softly
we tread again what is with that what is
with that donging sound that sounds like
a dong that happens when he gets yah
here we go here we go
where's that first page I don't remember
who's up to the LA ha oh is that the
bottom here that was it no that is it
yeah and then I'll assume that I grabbed
this at 60 seconds he'll get the F out
of her with their three scraps in here
Oh bollocks
Oh balls um on owned I am okay just
climb up I got sixties ding dong damn
seconds come on hurry all right come on
move those legs yeah I don't see a page
see a page do not pull me back in here
that would be the duty all you ball
bar Joe why are you still staticky I'm
not even looking near ya hodge-podge
fudge fudge fudge he's over there it's
like really static hang up my what is
that what is that what da
those are scrapped there what's with the
guitar music fudge maybe he's not here
and it's just all static I don't know
what's going on we're that guitar come
from I like it but why is it happening
where am I going
ah let me go yeah please
what what is this that the page here it
doesn't lead to anything
what's happening I does you - I did it -
tada
I did another door amount of time a text
what is going on I there was no page
there I spam the e button am I supposed
to get wait what ah oh oh oh oh please
tell me that wasn't a page up there that
I was supposed to get because I did not
see anything but of the boat it should
be just across the way straight across
from the fence oh my god I might
actually do this I like that song I like
it a lot
that static is now reassuring me oh
maybe the last page is by the boat oh oh
oh oh oh
Slendy do not get me please just let me
go keep playing your guitar off in la-la
land and i'll be on my way it should be
straight from here right yeah this this
is this it
yes hello bye ah right whoa what the
hell oh no the photo
Slendy uh-huh her eyes are the water oh
let me go let me go let me go let me go
let me go let me go Brett run to the
line yeah come on come on come on
how about what is this what's going on
I'm not getting any closer what's going
on here
oh did I
what would you do if you woke up in a
place you have never seen before
yeah huh ah we're done I did wait a
minute
what no it did not just what what
happened what where am I
what aw naw what how could I do it
then just restart was that it right
ah
oh I see oh I get it it started me out
on now paranormal
oh I see okay it restarted the game on
paranormal difficulty okay alright okay
that is the end of the game I have beat
it on gamer difficulty I don't know if
I'll ever tried on paranormal would take
a long time multiple parts lots of
gnashing of teeth and really cursing you
don't want to see any of that but anyway
that was great there was a reason why
when I first played this I said that it
was probably the best Thunder game to
come out so far because I had a really
cool story the graphics were amazing I'm
in the beginning sunder wasn't too
aggressive so it's kind of like yeah it
wasn't that scary but I mean they really
pumped him up after a bit and like it
it's just it seems like a lot of work
went into it and I really love when
people really try with he sings so I
really enjoyed it I hope you all liked
it to try to be the paranormal and if
there's something special there that you
think I should see and definitely see it
hang on let me go look at the extras
here oh oh he's got teh the mark slender
hey buddy you didn't look like that
before where's your chef's hat huh see
that's just a car it's a house with a
figure in the window that's the factory
okay okay let's try black and white ooh
HUD off black and white HUD on
I probably ought to beat it on
paranormal to see what that last one is
but let me just let me try something
real quick here I'm onna I turned in the
extras thing I turned the hut on and
black and white on I almost want to see
what the deal is
those just give you something else
because I mean we only let's still
enough time ooh ah that's what it means
it's in black and white and there's like
a camera thing going on hey now let's
see what Slendy looks like in black and
white oh and I actually have a battery
meter oh that's helpful
bill oh I'm inside Hey hi got my lawn
grabbed my lawn hi ah whoa William
whippersnapper all right so that it adds
a little bit I might you know if I ever
do anything else with this I might if
they update it I'm I played on black and
white with HUD on just to give it
something different but anyway hope you
enjoyed it thank you guys so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
Oh